wir wollen jetzt über diesen fall um vor
allem über die tückische krankheit
magersucht sprechen mit doktor eine flex
es uns nun zugeschaltet und
ernährungsmedizinerin frau deutschland
440.000 menschen leiden allein in
deutschland an essstörungen wie kann ich
erkennen ob mein kind meine freundin
mein partner auch dazugehört wenn das
vielleicht selber noch nicht zugeben
möchte klassischerweise beginnt diese
essstörung nach einer ausgeprägten
diätphase und wenn die jugendliche vor
allen dingen bei denen sollte man darauf
achten auch nicht nur mädchen sind
betroffen sondern auch zunehmend jungs
das nach einer diät auch zunehmend auf
essen verzichtet wird ausreden erfunden
werden ich habe jetzt keinen hunger mehr
oder andere ideen kommen warum man nicht
am essen teilnehmen will
und in diesem fall haben wir eine
klassische verbindung gesehen dass oft
nicht nur das gestörte essverhalten ein
problem ist sondern auch zunehmend eine
athletiker anorexia athletica das heißt
mit einem verstärkten sport wird dann
auch zusätzlich dass kaloriensparen de
es muster weiter verschärft wenn sie
gerade gesagt dass werden ausreden
gesucht warum man nicht am essen
teilnimmt natürlich hat man trotzdem
hunger das ist ja der menschliche trieb
wie kann es überhaupt sein dass die
psyche so viel stärker ist als unser uhr
verlangen danach zu essen wenn wir
hunger haben
klassischerweise ist oft ein ein
bedürfnis dieser menschen nach autonomie
sie haben oft einen sehr schlechten
selbst wird deswegen wäre mein tipp an
alle eltern geben sie den jungen
menschen genügend selbstwert das stärkt
nämlich auch das vertrauen in sich und
den eigenen körper und dieses streben
nach autonomie diesen einzigen erfolg
sozusagen den nimmt sich diese
patientengruppe über das essen und das
ist eigentlich voll dramatisch weil der
ganze tages bestimmt über den gedanken
was ich jetzt was sie beschäftigen sich
viel mehr mit dem essen diese menschen
einst ein großer gummi noch einmal sagen
ab wann hört so eine magersucht
lebensbedrohlich und was sind dafür die
in die k
man weiß dass die magersucht wirklich in
bis zu 30 prozent der fälle maximal
wirklich tödlich ist nicht akut aber
dass die betroffenen über die jahre an
den folgen dieser erkrankung sterben und
klassischerweise sie haben sie einen so
kritischen body-mass-index was aber auch
erschwerend hinzu kommt was wir in
diesem dramatischen fall sehen
durch den extremen störungs durch den
verlust von elektrolyten kommt es zu der
gefahr von herzrhythmusstörungen und
diese sind dann oft auch heimtückisch
kommen unberechenbar und enden dann in
der regel auch gerne tödlich vielen dank
für dieses gespräch und für diese
einblicke und wir wollen gleich
weitermachen und vor allem mit der
fragestellung was kann ich tun wenn ich
angehöriger wenn ich freund bin und
wollen darüber sprechen mit der
verhaltenstherapeutin jana reiche zahlen
guten abend vielen dank dass die zeit
für uns haben und gleich direkt an sie
noch mal die frage wenn wir so einen
fall im freundeskreis im bekanntenkreis
haben was raten sie angehörigen was
raten sie freunden wenn sie sich zu
haben muss und dass jemand in ihrem
bekanntenkreis betroffen ist nehmen sie
das auf jeden fall ernst und suchen sie
das gespräch mit der person im regelfall
haben die betroffenen selber ein gefühl
dafür wollen es aber häufig nicht
wahrhaben und deswegen das ist wichtig
mit fingerspitzengefühl so ein gespräch
zu beginnen
vermeiden sie vorwürfe benennen sie
einfach er ich mache mir sorgen um dich
ich habe das gefühl es geht ihr nicht
gut wie kann ich dich unterstützen was
brauchst du also bieten sie eher
unterstützung und hilfe an
als auf druck oder zwang zu setzen bevor
ich jetzt haben sie haben gerade gesagt
meistens die betroffenen wissen ist
eigentlich irgendwie schon selber
natürlich ist der schwerste schritt das
dann auch einzugestehen vor sich und vor
anderen dass man ein problem hat das ist
der größte und wichtigste schritt aber
was passiert danach wenn ich selber weiß
dass mein essverhalten nicht normales
und krankhaft ist genau sie haben gerade
schon gesagt der erste schritt ist
eigentlich zu sich selber ehrlich und
offen zu sein und zu erkennen
dass ich ein problem habe die anorexie
aber auch die anderen essstörungen sind
wirklich ernstzunehmende krankheiten und
gehören durch fachmänner behandelt daher
ist es wichtig zum arzt zu gehen zum
psychotherapeuten zu gehen vielleicht
eine fachspezifische klinik zu gehen um
sich behandeln zu lassen
in den seltensten fällen ist man in der
lage wirklich eine essstörung alleine zu
lösen wenn man sich zu hause versucht
alleine zu helfen
das körperliche das gewicht das essen
das ist eigentlich nur ein symptom für
das was darunter liegt die seelische
erkrankungen und problematik und das ist
auch das was die krankheit am leben
erhält und das quasi durch die therapie
gelöst wird josi marias in den letzten
monaten sehr ehrlich mit ihrer krankheit
vor allem auf instagram umgegangen hat
aber auch gesagt sie hat sich vorher
immer etwas dicker bearbeitet damit es
den menschen eben doch nicht ganz so
auffällt meistens sehen wir genau das
gegenteil bei instagram oder anderen
social medias ist es immer die perfekte
welt alle menschen sind dünn wie viel
einfluss denken sie haben auch instagram
und all die anderen apps vor allem auf
junge menschen die dort immer die
perfekten körper sehen
das hat auf jeden fall einen eindruck
vor allen dingen auch auf das wahrnehmen
eines normalen körpers häufig mit
magersucht einhergehend ist etwas was
wir körperschema störungen nennen das
heißt die betroffenen sehen ihren
eigenen körper verzehrt sie sehen ihren
eigenen körper als dicker war und je
mehr referenzpunkte wir haben zum
beispiel durch die sozialen medien wo
körper bearbeitet werden schlanker
gemacht werden desto andere maßstäbe
haben wir auch das so mehr verschieben
sich unsere maßstäbe dafür was normal
ist
ich kann mir vorstellen dass in unserer
heutigen gesellschaft schlanksein gleich
zugesetzt wird mit erfolg und mit
leistungen beliebtheit 1 einen faktor
gibt und mit reinspielt aber nicht der
alleinige faktor ist
ich denke es ist einer von mehreren
faktoren die dann in so einem konzept
zusammen kommen und so die entstehung so
einer krankheit begünstigen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren